turning now to the powerful storm
pounding California it has claimed two
lives including a toddler this is the
latest system known as the atmospheric
River to sweep across California in
recent days a state of emergency is in
effect as Crews race to respond to power
outages flooding and mudslides nearly
200 000 homes and businesses are without
power Jonathan bigliotti is in
Sacramento County Jonathan good morning
and good morning to you Nate we're here
in the town of Wilton outside the city
of Sacramento which received the
equivalent of one month's worth of
rainfall and less than 24 hours the
Levee system which was meant to hold
back the river it broke in several
locations during last weekend's storm
which is why we're seeing this
incredible amount of flooding the river
here the water here expected to rise as
the day continues on meteorologists
describing this storm as brutal it has
already proven to be deadly
the damage has already begun across the
bay area and Central Coast and for at
least one family overnight heartbreak we
had a fatality up there of uh
of a minor the town of occidental's fire
chief ronaldi described the events
following a tree falling on the mobile
home of a family of three killing a
toddler when I first arrived on seeing a
frantic father came out of the household
of the child and he said my child's not
breathing lunardi went on to say
paramedics were unable to revive the
child
Knight also saw rescues across the area
including a crew saving this man from
the fast running Los Gatos Creek in San
Jose we anticipate that this may be one
of the most challenging and impactful
series of storms to touch down in
California in the last five years
authorities are warning residents to
stay indoors and off the roads unless
order to evacuate they just said that we
have to leave
and for good reason Following last
weekend's storm late yesterday we
witnessed one man discover his sister's
car submerged in a Sacramento County
Vineyard he told us he'd been searching
for her for the past three days
emergency crews arrived and recovered
her body at least three deaths have been
linked to the holiday Deluge with the
saturation of the water it's not going
to take much to overwhelm communities
and back here in Wilton Crews worked up
against the clock to repair the Levee a
broken five areas they were unable to
fix it all this Levee system was
recently restored to last until 2050 it
cost 20 million dollars Adriana it took
just one storm to cause this much
destruction
Jonathan thank you